foreign
hey you guys flickers of fear time once
again and once again I have one of these
weird ass movies
that I seem to love but seem to be kind
of divisive everywhere else
so let's get into it I don't recall
exactly when I was first made aware of
this movie uh which came out originally
in 2018 like did the rounded festivals
and stuff and is called braid I'm pretty
sure that I read about it on one of
those lists sometimes at like different
horror sites will put up like best
horror movies of the 2010s or you know
movies you know on Netflix or whatever
the hell that you want to see and I tend
to like kind of peruse those from time
to time just to get like ideas on what
to what to watch next do you know what I
mean because I do kind of like there's
so many horror movies coming out and I
need like some a little bit of somebody
curating stuff so I'm not just like
watching a bunch of crap all the time so
the premise of braid from the little
that I read of it like on this horror
list that I don't remember
sounded kind of intriguing back then I
think this was in 2019 or 2020.
um but I kind of sort of forgot about it
until I actually saw it pop up to stream
for free on 2B the other day so I
thought well [ __ ] I had been wanting to
see that actually so I'm gonna give it a
spin and you know because I was kind of
eager to see like what it was all about
because like I said it sounded really
weird and I'm into that now I am going
to give a caveat up front however I
actually liked this film a lot but it's
definitely like I said it's definitely
one of those divisive movies you will
either absolutely Vibe with this and
like dig it immensely as I did or you
will watch it and roll your eyes at it
because maybe because like it seems like
meaningless style over substance to you
or weirdness for the sake of being weird
um because I admit that it is pretty
damn weird
I would also suggest avoiding this if
you're not a big fan of like real Acid
Trip type visuals
um a narrative that is very not
straightforward like that's kind of like
fractured and maybe seems like a little
bit senseless like on first viewing and
a bewildering away array of like
possible interpretations now if you're
the kind of person that doesn't like
movies like that then stay far far away
from this because uh if you watch it
you're probably gonna have a bad time
now while I was watching this I was
actually reminded of a few other movies
like here and there it's not exactly
like these but this is kind of like in
the same area
um I think the movie that it reminded me
of the most was we have always lived in
the castle which also came out in 2018
which if you don't know is an adaptation
of a Shirley Jackson novel from 1962 had
Crispin Glover in it among other people
uh so it kind of reminded me of that a
little bit also caught big whiffs of the
1994 film Heavenly Creatures which is
kind of like a Fantastical take on like
a real true crime type story
um which is actually really good if you
haven't seen it Kate Winslet was in it
um little bit had got a little bit of
like um excision from 2012 which is
great if you haven't seen it and maybe
even a Sprinkle of the neon demon like
from 2016. like I said it's not exactly
like any of those but that's kind of
like the ballpark that we're in it's
like kind of surreal a little bit you
know hyper real a little bit like
hyperkinetic like a very very stylized
in places so if you liked any of those
movies then there's like a good chance
that you'll probably like this one as
well oh and here's a fun fact that I
discovered while I was doing some
research on this movie uh this is
actually the first movie in the history
of filmmaking that was entirely funded
with cryptocurrency
um not that you would know that
necessarily from watching it but you
know I found that an interesting little
factoid that might help me out if I ever
turn up on Jeopardy one day so this this
was written and directed by Mitzi Perron
now this is her feature length debut I
believe she'd made a couple of short
films prior to this but this is her
feature length uh first feature-link
film uh it was also released as far as I
know under a couple of alternate titles
one of those being dying to play and the
other one being nobody leaves
so braid is focused pretty much
exclusively on three characters you have
Petula who's played by Imogen Waterhouse
who was in nocturnal animals you have
Tilda who's played by Sarah may she or
Sarah hey rather sorry uh she was in
Black Swan and the mortuary collection
which is getting great if you haven't
seen that it's a Anthology and Daphne
who's played by probably the most famous
uh you know actor in this Madeleine
Brewer who was in cam she was an Orange
is the New Black she's on handmaid's
tale so you know what I mean so she's in
it uh as well so at the beginning of the
story uh patchilla and Tilda who are
living in New York City uh looks like
New York City and they kind of live like
in a sort of shitty apartment they're
kind of anticipating all the money
they're gonna make by from this big drug
score that they just got they're kind of
like counting out like all the drugs in
their apartment being like Oh it's all
this money and when we sell these we're
gonna get out of here and like you know
make our dreams come true and all that
kind of stuff however while they're in
the middle of counting out all the money
like all the drugs and everything like
that so all the drugs are spread out all
over the floor
um the cops come to the door and start
like raiding the place so they have to
flee their apartment
now they actually end up escaping like
with their lives and their freedom
intact obviously but they were forced to
leave over 80 grand worth of product
behind and their dealer Coco who we
actually never see or hear
um you know we just see her like talking
to him her whoever it is like on the
phone but you never hear their voice or
anything uh so Coco has given them 48
hours to get that 85 Grand or whatever
it is like back you know get him his
money back so they're not really sure
what else to do so they decide to travel
back to their implied hometown of
Montpelier Vermont uh and that's where
their childhood friend Daphne still
lives now there's kind of a sequence
where they're on the train like going to
Vermont and the implication here is that
Petula is maybe kind of like well known
like maybe she's some kind of like cam
girl or something like that because her
and Tilda like didn't buy tickets they
just like stowed away on the train I
guess and like one when one of the
conductors like comes along looking for
the tickets like she he seems to
recognize her and he's like leering at
her all creepily and she like drags him
into a bathroom and he calls her goddess
and like starts licking her shoe and
stuff like that so it's implied that
like that's what she's been doing for
money and like she's famous enough that
a random dude would like know who she is
so they're going back to Montpelier
Vermont their friend Daphne who it's you
know you're led to assume was their
friend from childhood she lives in very
very wealthy Splendor now she has
inherited Daphne has this massive estate
and presumably a fortune like after the
recent death of her grandparents I'm not
sure if it's said like exactly how long
ago it was but you're led to think that
it was like fairly recent
however Daphne is also severely mentally
ill uh so much so that she seems to have
very very little connection to reality
at all she just lives in this massive
massive Mansion all by herself and just
kind of lives in her own like you know
isolated fantasy world essentially
on Tilda uh then surmise that they're
going to be able to search Daphne's
house to find the safe that they believe
is hidden on the premises and you know
thereby obtaining all the money they'll
ever need and then they'll be able to
again like I said start their lives Anew
now even before they go back there
they're very aware that this plan that
they have comes with a price
if they go back to Daphne's house
they're going to have to play the game
now this game which is revealed to have
originated in the three girls childhood
um basically only has three very
inflexible rules everyone must play no
Outsiders allowed and no one leaves so
the game as it sort of starts to unfold
over the course of the movie is you know
this kind of like bizarre essentially
like a role-playing exercise I guess
like Daphne is always playing the role
of like the firm but doting Mother
character Tilda is you know the dutiful
daughter who has to do everything that
mother tells her to do no matter how
[ __ ] up and Petula is the visiting
Doctor Who actually sees to the
daughter's ailments and uh even gives
mother some you know bedside manner Some
Lovin on the side like when the mood
arises like I said you have to do
everything that mother says that's like
part of the game so and you know Daphne
is not not right so she comes up with
like some pretty messed up stuff and you
have to do it so from that point uh the
narrative begins to kind of unspool and
warp in very very bizarre and kind of
wonderful ways it's very uh Alice
Through the Looking Glass type of thing
um and you watching it you're kind of
left with the distinct sense that you
might possibly also be losing your mind
like right alongside the characters
because kind of the concept of time and
continuity like starts becoming ever
more slippery like as the movie goes on
like for example like Petula and Tilda
they go on this like PCP fueled Bender
at one point and they're like running
through the outside and everything is
like magenta like everyone's hair is
purple and magenta like it's like hyper
colored and like weird and saturated and
then they'll like run through hallways
and it's all like upside down and [ __ ]
up it's like like I said it's like real
trippy
um there's one point there's like some
violence in this as well like Petula for
example
um in her role as Doctor she's trying to
do like the whole reflexes thing and uh
it's not working out to Mother
satisfaction so basically Petula has to
bash till this kneecap with a meat
tenderizer but then like that's really
never referred to again like it happens
and it looks like really [ __ ] up and
painful but then like it seems to be
healed in the next scene or like a
couple scenes down the line
um there's one scene too where Daphne
like ties the two other women like back
to back like with their it looks like
their own hair but it's like really
really really long and braided like
clearly much longer than their real hair
is you know and that they're kind of
tied up but then they seem to escape
without explanation because like the
next scene or two they're like free
again and nobody brings it up again
uh there's one scene where Petula is
kind of simulating sex with Daphne uh
and then after that Daphne insists that
she's pregnant like all kind of crazy
[ __ ] like that happens now at one stage
there's kind of like a flashback
sequence where it where they seem to
suggest that when all three girls were
children Petula and Tilda
accidentally on purpose kind of like
pushed Daphne out of their tree house
like while they were arguing about the
game uh which caused actually like a
devastating injury that rendered Daphne
infertile uh hence her continued
insistence on playing the mother role or
so you're led to assume so while all of
this like trippy Fantasia is going on
you also have lingering around the
fringes is the soul male character
detective Siegel who's actually played
by Scott Cohen who I think was on
Gilmore Girls and the 10th Kingdom and
stuff so he actually knew these three
girls as children and he suspected even
back then that Petula and Tilda had
pushed Daphne from the tree deliberately
like all those years ago now in the
present day he actually like arrives at
Daphne's remote Mansion after neighbors
have reportedly called the police and
said that they heard women screaming
from inside the mansion
and so uh so detective Siegel comes
there and he's pretty convinced because
he knew like that all of them were
friends like back in the day so he is
led to assume that Petula and Tilda who
are fugitives from Justice like I said
because they were drug dealers and they
found all their drugs in their apartment
back in New York City
um and they you know there's missing
posters and I'm like all over town and
he's pretty sure that Daphne is like
um hiding them somewhere in the house
but he can't really prove it and he
doesn't have a warrant
um but Daphne is like acting so weird
that it's obvious that she knows more
than she's letting on but like I said he
can't really just like storm in there
even though he's pretty sure that the
girls are in there somewhere and he even
uh says to her it's like you know you
might think that you're taking advantage
of them but they're actually like taking
advantage of you so there's kind of like
this switch everything going on so as
the events grow ever more surreal and
like ever more violent uh time and
structure start to break down even
further and the movie kind of starts to
to seem more and more like a really
unsettling fever dream now I won't spoil
the ending but suffice it to say that
this is a very ambiguous movie that
almost Demands a second viewing like I
kind of feel like there's all these very
tantalizing like threads of meaning and
they're kind of like hovering just Out
Of Reach and like begging you to like
put them back together now you're led to
assume and maybe uh you know because
like I said there's lots of
interpretations of this but I thought
that you are supposed to think that
whatever like most of the stuff that
happened like at this isolated Mansion
wasn't real but it's not super clear
like where the line between like reality
and Imagination is I actually have a
couple theories of my own about what is
what or who uh is real in this scenario
um all I'll say about that is that the
reason that the movie is called braid at
least in my opinion uh is that a braid
is obviously like three sections of hair
are like woven together into one thing
like one section uh so I'm thinking
maybe that might be making some kind of
like metaphorical statement about the
relationship of these three women with
one another I could be totally off base
on that but like I said this is a movie
that really you I think you need to see
it like at least twice like to really
kind of figure out what's going on
because it's kind of like crazy and all
over the place so I mean whether you
find braid like a layered kind of
visually stunning exploration of
escalating Madness perhaps or you know
on the other hand I have seen some
critics just called it a beautiful
looking but incomprehensible mess that's
trying too hard uh you know to be like
Artie
um that's kind of entirely up to you in
your own sensibilities I mean it's
neither one of those positions is
correct obviously it's just going to be
subjective
um I absolutely loved the look of this
movie um I loved the score the acting is
fantastic and I really really liked this
kind kind of intriguing puzzle that it
presented and I was like never even
though like sometimes I'd be like what
the [ __ ] is going on but it's like it
never it was always interesting like it
never made me like oh Jesus Christ it
never did that like I was always I was
all in
um but I can see how some viewers might
find it I don't know just like
frustratingly opaque maybe or strange
for strangeness's sake like I said
um if you have any interest at all like
in any of the movies that I mentioned
earlier like I said Heavenly Creatures
or we um we've always always lived in
the castle or excision or something like
that then um you'll probably like really
get into this too but if not like if you
don't like that kind of thing then I
really hesitate to recommend it because
you'll probably just hate it
um but I thought it was like outstanding
like an outstanding debut feature so I'm
really looking forward to what this
writer director is going to do in the
future because I thought this movie was
really cool and like I said uh it's free
on 2B if you want to check it out but
like I said I'm not going to recommend
it across the board because I know that
some people really really don't like
movies like this and uh like I do but I
understand that people don't and that's
totally fine but you know if it sounds
like you're jammed then I think you
should like check it out because I
thought it was like pretty awesome so
that will do it for this flickers of
fear and I'll see you guys again on the
next one bye